Hamas invaded into Israel into Israel
and started killing civilians over 5,000
Rockets were fired targeting civilian
areas and it's pretty extreme in
response to this Israel has declared a
full Siege on Gaza and now we're
watching buildings being flattened and
of course you've got people on the left
defending Palestine and then you
actually have establishment more
establishment Democrat uh types
criticizing the far-left and actually
advocating for more Aid and uh in
defense of Israel with many
conservatives split as as well
interestingly this uh this issue has has
divided everybody quite a bit with many
on the right under Trump being either
very defensive of Israel or very anti
anti- intervention it gets interesting
when you look at exactly what went down
and the big news that's happening now so
oh boy do we have a lot to talk about
here there are hostages being murdered
right now by Hamas there are threats to
execute more hostages as Israel
retaliates and fires into Gaza and
there's reports that the hostages may
contain American citizens